thank you and welcome to the meeting of
extra
Wednesday the 13th September 2023
um the milk meeting is filmed live and
recorded on YouTube
um so can I remind counselors and guests
when you speak to please press the
microphone button and then turn it off
at the end otherwise you can't hear it
on the YouTube recording for people
listening apologies
yesterday we've had apologies from
councilor Brenton councilor Hawkins and
councilor Smith counselor Wheatley is
substitute uh councilor Hawkins is here
oh sorry I didn't see you
sorry
[Laughter]
apology we've had we've had apologies
for counselor Brenton and councilor
Smith Council Wheatley who substitutes
thank you thank you
um and we'll go through the minutes uh
I'll go through Page by Page
page I'll do the page numbers at the
tops they paid one
page two
page three
page four and page five are there any
issues with any matters arising everyone
happy with the minutes
so I'll propose them from the check and
I get a second though
kitchens
two episodes I think Chris you have
Spain
thank you
well then Steve
and public participation
um we've got guests who we've invited in
so I don't think we've got any formal
members of the public thank you
right the action list pages eight to ten
it's got quite a lot on here but I think
a lot of them are complete they can be
taken off
so the first one is about Southwest
water providing presentation slides this
was put on here quite a long time ago
and now that we've set up the water
quality working group I think we can
probably take that one off if everyone's
happy and follow up through the water
quality group that was agreed at full
Council
so take that one off
um next one's about Dentistry
so we have had some responses
um
from the cabinet lead at Devon County
Council and I've just spoken to
councilor Hudson as well and it's on the
health and adult social care scrutiny
meeting next week 21st of September
about dental access so if anyone wants
to attend it's down at County Hall but
you can also view it online
and we've been speaking to North Devon
Council and we'd like to have
a meeting a scrutiny meeting in joint
with tourism North Devon on Dentistry so
it'd be good if we view what is said at
County hall and then we can take that
into consideration when we have a
meeting ourselves and how it affects
tourism North Devon if everyone's in
agreement
so should we take take that one off
thank you
um District Hospital site
um
Karen you've sent out various letters
um from their last meeting chair it was
requested that I um Chase up the letter
that we sent to see if there was a
response and to raise concerns around
the change of CEOs so I've done that but
I haven't but we haven't heard anything
back from and we hope from Jeffrey Cooks
I was so not yet we'll follow that one
up again as well we'll leave leave that
one on there then
um to external regarding mental health
and Link Center provision
Unfortunately they have been unable to
attend
we offered to change the dates but they
refused and said instead that we should
go through our representative
representative councilor Hudson who sits
on the scrutiny committee
representing us at the County Hall
so
and we also
we thought that we had a few more people
attending as well but then they said
we're actually
it needs to go through the County
Council instead of attending this
meeting so it's a bit disappointing
um
so we can take that one off
yeah that's fine thank you
um
and the next one we'll leave on it's
about the police bite size training or
we could raise it with yet
but we've got the community safety
partnership where we agreed that we'd
raise
um
the issues with wanting to have the
training that we've had previously as
counselors to help us working with the
police
maybe you can take that back as well to
Ewan
um
it was like courses on county lines and
different local issues that as
councilors we might be able to help on
and we used to have training for around
four years ago but it's not available at
the moment and we didn't know if that
could be something that could be
provided
jointly on meetings and dentistry and
agriculture
so we'll leave that on because that's
all going
any questions
no okay
so now
separation of Interest members of
Interest should refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interests when the item is considered
agreement of agenda items part one and
two there is no part two
any urgent matters brought forward of
permission of the chair
oh is that
so I was wondering this is just today is
for the forward plan as well really
um two o'clock doesn't work very well
with me for school pickup so I was
wondering if we could change the two
o'clock meetings in future to 10 o'clock
would that be agreeability
is everyone else happy with so you'll
still have the six o'clock but instead
of having an alternate two o'clock it
would be six o'clock and ten o'clock
everyone happy we need to vote on it
it's no good for me chair oh no
um
what time would be
two o'clock be perfect for me tonight
um
I don't know what to say
should we put in turn the foot and then
as we go along see how it fits in
yeah the first meeting is the 6th of
December
and then the next one is the 13th of
March so those are the two remaining two
o'clock meeting that we've changed today
sorry thank you yeah
at all um
with regards to this committee is is
stagecoached the uh the passenger bus
service something that can come to this
committee because I've had an awful lot
of complaints recently about various
Services they've reduced them and we
understand the reasons why
has that ever happened in the past where
you've can that be done
I haven't known them come in the past
but I'm not sure if is it someone that
we
can certainly invite them and see if
they'll attend
I have been to them
most unhelpful response
just saying it's cutbacks but it seems a
bit early that they've kept up the 21
service already you know with so many
people still around it just seems a bit
odd and I I would really like to suggest
that they come in and explain what's
happening to the bus services generally
thank you
yeah we can put that later on the floor
plan
you raised there was some was that to do
with transport well I wanted to um
maybe get Devon highways in my my
concern is the state of the roads around
here
um when I recognize that we're unlikely
to get any more spending out of Devon
but I wonder about
the decisions that be made of which bits
of which roads are being repaired and
which aren't
um there seems to be various bits of
patching and repairs going on someone
roads that aren't that bad whereas there
are sections of Road certainly around
bideford which are an absolutely
appalling statement have been for years
and I'm just wondering if we can get
someone from Devon to actually come and
explain what are their priorities and
whether we can actually have any
influence on deciding which roads are
viewed as a priority I'm just wondering
about is that hat hook would that be the
body
so there is a group who do we know who
the representatives are
there are a couple of District
councilors that sit on hat what does
that stand for
it's the transport highways
yeah cancel that sorry chair um Dermot
mcgough is now chair of haddock was he
currently so yeah all right
that's interesting
just further to the councilor's point
about Stagecoach I've also seen a lot of
reports
um regarding the timetable the fact that
bosses just seem to come along
willy-nilly and the timetable services
are not being delivered it's not just
cut backs they're not coming when
they're supposed to come so I think if
we can get them to talk to us it would
be good
Stagecoach part of hatock
is there any other urgent matters
so now we go on to the main part of the
meeting mental health provision
um
so the purpose of the meeting is we
haven't we don't know what the
consultation questions are yet but it's
to get an idea of mental health
provision in storage and what we can do
as a district council
um
social services and users of the link
center as well to give us a bit of
detail and then hopefully at the end we
can put forward some proposals
that will help to support it
okay so there was a few questions that
were sent out
not sure how we want to
go back does someone want to go first
and
would you like to go first save us
um
[Music]
could you introduce who you are yeah I'm
Sue Matthews I want to excuse me one of
the save our Hospital services
campaigners in North Devon a saber
Hospital Services was set up in 2016 in
response to the Devon ccg uh acute
Services review which threatened the
services in North Stafford and we feel
that we were successfully
represented in that because the services
in North Devon have been retained apart
from some of the services in the
Community Hospitals
um and our remit since then has extended
somewhat into Health Services rather
than Hospital services
in
2021 we were approached by members of
the service users of Link centers to say
that this consultation had begun which
again was not well circulated to the
general public as they generally aren't
um and so we set up some meetings with
Link Center service users with members
of the public to find out what was
happening and and basically the link
centers had closed uh during the pack uh
the pandemic a very few of their service
users had been contacted during that
time
because Devon County council's provision
had been changed without service users
knowledge
um identifying a specific group of those
service users as those that fitted
within the Health and Social Care Act
rather than all of the service users
that had previously used these um with
well over 700 people a week using those
services
they were limited in time in places like
holsworthy which had been reduced over
over a significant period of time and
effectively closed prior to the pandemic
um the the other three centers the
service users had been
using the center since 1992 but they
were set up as a consequence of the
Health and Social Care Act in 1990 where
it was recognized that we've all heard
of care in the community I can see we're
all of an age we knew about care in the
community and what was happening in
terms of the closure of of large
institutions and North Devon's set up
these four centers very successfully
supporting people across the community
in all all of the issues that they had
to live with on a day-to-day basis
um so it may be people who had a a a a a
breakdown as a consequence of a life
event it may be someone who had a severe
and enduring mental illness who needed
supervision and support and monitoring
of medication and so on but bearing in
mind that a lot of people have have
shown the degree of stress that life
brings on them these days whether it's
through work or family circumstances
Finance is a really big one
um and so the link center staff assisted
those people in managing their
day-to-day lives on a place of safety
somewhere that was a stable opportunity
for people to go in and talk make
friends socialize and actually use the
centers and be provided with services
that helps them to live their lives
this was incredibly successful up until
the pandemic period but we were aware or
became aware of the fact that there was
discussions about reducing the services
or closing the services just prior to
the pandemic and the staff have shared
the fact that they were part of a
staffing review on how how they would
work but that didn't ever come into the
public domain until the pandemic period
and as a consequence of the first
consultation shall we call it
individuals in external venues or in
their own homes rather than in a a
center in each of the main towns
um that uh the because of the focus
being on individuals rather than on
groups it would no longer help
individuals to
look at the socialization aspects to
have their own self-help groups develop
activities and skills that they needed
for their for their daily lives and it
certainly wouldn't help the families of
those people who obviously were also
affected by people with mental health
problems because they were also part of
the if you like the family that were
using the link centers
so 98 of the response said this is
wholly inappropriate GPS
a consultant a psychiatrist that some
people may know Jeremy Holmes who
retired a couple of years before the
um
consultation process began but was an
instigator of some of the services that
were provided with the link centers was
more than happy to respond and to offer
his professional opinion he's still a
professor at Exeter University so it's
still very valid and has that
responsibility and was very clear that
as far as he was concerned this was a
disaster and that people in North Devon
particularly as a consequence of the
increased demands
through covid and the iso social
isolation does not replace a four times
a week dropping to be able to check up
on things and we're talking about very
fairly fundamental things people were
being you know having to fill in their
own pip forms their a lot of their own
benefits forms not even having access to
to the internet they relied on the link
centers for such fundamental things and
the staff to advise them on how to
manage it
and with all of the other areas closed
the cab and other organizations these
things fell by the wayside so right
while you're on your own had a fairly
disastrous effect on some people
so in during the time after the
consultation had closed we had a number
of meetings sohs organized a number of
meetings with the commissioner for the
link center service Adam Carrick who at
that time was the
um
deputy director of Mental Health
Services for Devon County Council and
the director for the newly developed
integrated care board now known as one
Devon
um so he came to those meetings and he
heard from 20 30 or more service users
these were public meetings we were aware
of the fact that the staff were told
quite specifically that they must not
attend these meetings and thankfully
towards the end of the session of
meetings some of them did
but he heard directly what the impact
was he made a number of agreements about
having Town meetings with councilors who
were interested with professionals who
wanted to get involved and with service
users none of those happened
so for nearly 18 months promises were
being made
that were never adhered to
at the same time sohs has had regular
meetings with some of the directors of
the integrated care board and raise this
matter constantly
and the last meeting that we had that
involved Adam Carrick was in January of
this year
and at that meeting he told us that
despite the Devon County Council cabinet
decision that the link centers should
reopen and provide full services
um it was likely that that would never
happen
and in fact he was no longer employed by
Devon County Council they had removed
that post from their
um their work arrangements and basically
showing that they had no intention of
taking the responsibilities that they
legally have to do to
provide Community Mental Health
to to Devon so that's not just in North
Devon that's across the county
Adam is still employed but there's no
doubt that Devon County Council made it
clear at that point that they were they
were devolving any responsibility for
mental health services to either the
third sector or into the health sector
which the link centers are in buildings
owned by Devon County Council but the
service staff the service specifications
and supervision are provided by Devon
partnership so it's a very professional
service that's been provided and the
proposal has been and we're now into
that we were into the third consultation
process
cutting cutting a quite a swathe of of
meetings off about closure of the link
centers and the proposals have been all
the way along that the the
service users should use the so-called
widely available
um voluntary services or voluntary
sector services that are available to
provide support for them
and that the link center should close
currently I'm aware that there are other
organizations involved having put legal
challenge in but there is still a very
clear message that the closure of the
link centers is is their full intention
and I I
sohs are extremely concerned because
we've tried since January to get a clear
picture about what's going on we were
promised meetings that would be a public
meeting to allow service users to come
as well with the Mental Health Alliance
who are providing similar services in
Southwest Devon and Exeter and East
Devon and those meetings have never gone
ahead despite our repeated requests
so
I suppose the the sad element of this is
that the Mental Health Alliance has and
does provide and these are organizations
these services but nevertheless they are
not statutory bodies
um
they are not involved in North Devon at
the moment even though they're
advertising for roles to be used in
North Devon
and they are not providing the services
that the link centers previously did
the other issue here is that the the
availability and access for people with
mental health and and severe mental
health and enduring illness is that the
majority of these services are online
and I looked at the one Devon website
today
which talks about their recognize engage
and accept process and the peer support
for people with mental health
and and the suicide awareness and
prevention program there are 38
organizations identified and
35 of them are accessible online
so if you don't have the access or the
knowledge of the internet sufficiently
to to follow up all of those previous
issues that they the link center clients
often attended the link centers for
support then there's no way they can
access any of that support which is
what's being signposted at the moment
so the issues that we have are about the
uh you know the hospitals and the GP
surgeries are now open but the link
centers are not open providing the
previous
um Services the uh and and in fact
um at the scrutiny committee meeting in
July after the link centers and others
challenged to the financial
um
um financial reasons for closing the
link centers when we know that closing
them has increased as the amount of
police Hospital Hospital admissions
acute Hospital
involvement is far more expensive than
the amount of money that it costs to to
run the link centers and I think that
the
director of Public Health
highlighted the inequalities of Health
the whilst you didn't and the rest of
Devon
so it's not just mental health it's the
whole of the health agenda
and we've seen a fall in the um the the
older people's age even though the the
population has increased enormously
we've seen a reduction in Mental Health
Services we've seen a reduction in quite
a lot of the other acute services and he
was very clear that this has to be
addressed now the the um I'm aware of
the questions and perhaps we should
address them afterwards once you've
heard from the other speakers is that
okay thank you thank you
would anyone like to raise the knee
questions at this point
thanks
um Anna did you want to speak uh yeah
thank you um pretty much Sue's covered
everything which
um
um a friend of Northern link centers and
what Sue has already spoken about is
what I pretty much wanted to raise
anyway
um with the also with the
um I don't know whether everybody knows
that we did actually manage to get the
proposal foreclosure was drawn and we
are currently waiting for a new proposal
from Devon County to come forward
um
one of the offices under uh councilman
McGinnis did say possibly this month but
so far there hasn't been any um any sign
of it yet although there is an adult
Health and Social care cabinet meeting
on the 21st of September I do believe
um
but I haven't looked at the agenda to
see if the link centers are going to be
raised under that particular meeting
um I don't think they are
um so again it's always
um so again it's a waiting game for the
next consultation and proposal to come
out
um so we're already waiting for it to
come out so we can pick through it again
and see what's not right and obviously
challenging that again
um we are still waiting for information
from certain people at Devon County for
information about
um like whether they get the costings
from where do they find this information
whether they basically what is it based
on
um we did manage to
um
challenge McGinnis and so his officer
survey right when they visited ivcume
Link Center
and they seem to try and push the blame
back onto Devon partnership trusts
um saying that they only based their
consultation or proposal on what they've
told them which sounds very disingenuous
to me
um apparently they were also told not to
go visiting the link centers at the very
beginning of all these consultations
because it might stir the pot
um I think it's more of a stir now than
what it was would have been at the
beginning
um what uh I seem to gather from solvo
right and James McGinnis is that
they thought what I said was that they
didn't they didn't realize how much
involved the link centers are with the
um support and recovery of so many
people and how much the staff actually
do it um they seem to think that the
link centers would just drop in for
people with mental health which does
plenty of other provision for that kind
of what level and they kept on thinking
it was for mild mental health and I
think they now realize it's not it's for
all severities and most people that
attend the link centers have complex
needs of course in the mental health
um
and one of the things
we kept trying to tell Devon county is
that
the link centers were pre-pandemic a
mental health Hub which is what the NHS
Community Mental Health framework is
aiming for we already had them
pre-pandemic but since the reopening
they strangled the service
um there's no
um the staff are not allowed to run
therapy groups or activities
um so we're just like it is at the
moment like a drop in however the staff
do still give us one-to-ones if we need
it and things like that
um
yeah at the moment is what another thing
is that at the moment there are no
referral routes to link centers opened
because obviously the amount of people
that need support
you know is I can I don't even I don't
even know how to quantize it but from
when we've spoken to people at the
public there is a lot of people who need
that kind of support even if it's
because even if they're at the start of
their journey of trying to get help from
the community mental health Team but
there's no referrals from the community
mental health Team there's no referrals
from the GPU practices and
self-referrals are non-existent either
um
now
trying I don't know how to go about
actually persuading Devon County to
reopen as referral routes and but we are
going to try
um but if this committee could
petition as well I was thinking at the
end when we look at proposals whether we
can how we can support what you've got
on your petition there that would be
great but if you because we want the
referrals to be opened and for staff to
be allowed to run the groups again
because that's what they're good at
they're they're very good and very
experienced in getting people to engage
in trying something even if it's a scary
thing to them and also it's a sport of
like perhaps going out on little
activities like the staff would
sometimes arrange a little outing once
in a while like to like rhs rose more or
um I don't know there was a game game
club weren't there in the High Street we
had a stint there um one afternoon and
but we had to support the staff to be
able to go
um and all of that is non-existent right
now the staff are as frustrated as us
because they they've got the skills
they've got the qualifications they've
got the experience and the motivation to
want to help people
and they can help more people in Under
One Roof than what they're inviting us
there's quite a few of us when was it
last week or the week before to visit
the link center and we really got a feel
of what it was all about and it's like
you're saying it's about the community
within link center it's not just a drop
in and you were talking about the
activities that you used to do so it was
a huge list mindfulness cooking choir
Tai Chi Pilates walk and talk poetry
guitar lessons coach trips badminton and
the Methodist Hall and a mobile Library
van used to stop over but none of it has
been reinstated
um and Sonia he showed me about the
Wellness Recovery action plans which
they used to work through together as a
group but all of that has stopped and
that would that was really helpful in
the past
um people were discharged and looked
down with no right to appeal
they used to be able to self-refer and
get guidance from staff and they used to
be longer so it's not just about the
closures of the think centers that
they're proposing it's about bringing it
back to what it used to be and having
that stability and consistency for
people because it's you're sort of in
limbo at the moment aren't you and
that's not going to have a positive
impact on any of the service users how
it's how it is at the moment regardless
of the proposals to close it it needs to
be fully reinstated to benefit everybody
um suddenly had to give up to add
anything
fun gold
service user
um we met with the councilman kid
McInnis and Solvay Wright
they have said they will visit all three
centers
nothing has been arranged us yet
I actually need the support you've got
no
real idea at the moment
um there's been a lot of people on the
bridge
you know that it seems prolific at the
moment every
week or so for a few days there's
someone on one of the bridges
and
where do they get the figures from
we used to have social interactions with
like The Breakfast Club and the walk and
talk a lot of us
social anxiety and
stuck with
try and combat that
taking us out at me
in a group it's a little bit more
tolerable yeah
um and we also used to have like it was
an early evening so I think it was sort
of
I finished it so half six I believe
then you've got
different times you can go rather than
just being
on the internet into the afternoon
and that meant people who worked could
then get support as well yeah so
we just want our service back
and we want to be able to
to feel safe and secure again because I
know I don't I'm sure
there's the users don't know
thinking it's not just because the
provisions say
provided
haven't worked
and then when we attended we talked
about the complex needs of the service
users so people are being referred to
talk works but actually that's not
satisfactory it's not helping the people
in the way that they need the help and
they need to be referred to the link
center but they're not so what's
happening to these people at the moment
and problems
if you have got a diagnosis
and you
don't love you
so
what what about the people who
haven't got access to things new phone
talk works and to find out there's no
help
and there's nothing else available in
this
yeah yeah
obviously Sonia and Anna have
demonstrated some of the issues and how
they feel about the importance of the
link centers but the fact is that
there's been no Alternatives proposed by
Devon County Council or debt partnership
Trust
so it's it is just literally pulling the
rug from underneath all of these service
users
what I was going to say and and Anna
covered there briefly
the Community Mental Health framework
for deafen
specifically has identified the
Community Mental Health hubs which have
been opened in South Devon and Plymouth
on the North Devon model
and that's the real kick in the teeth
and they they opened last September
after we'd highlighted the you know how
important the link centers were so it's
not that we're trying to take away
anything from anyone else it's about
providing what's already been there and
that provision has been you know so
successful we know there's been an
increase in the number of attendances
right Devin County
um has one of the high suicide rates in
the country which
really doesn't
look in the way you'd expect in a county
that has so much to offer as Devon this
huge social
um deprivation in both Rural and coastal
areas there's been so much written about
it and Devin one definitely saying oh
we're going to do something about it
it's part of their plan by 2028 but the
link centers don't feature anywhere in
that work
and as far as the referrals are
concerned the GPS and the well-being
teams in the GP surgeries are desperate
for the link centers to reopen and
provide the services that they did
previously the GPS have very vocally
identified with Devon County Council the
importance of the link centers I
mentioned the consultant psychiatrist a
lot of the a lot of counselors have also
written and joined with petitions and
with the sohs communications
um and and just just as a a final
mention really Terry Elliott councilor
Terry Elliott from ilfrakum who you'll
have met and um has been very supportive
of the link center in ilfracombe has now
written a formal letter to solving and
she's given me permission to share that
letter with you if you would like
yesterday yeah
and follow it sorry Anna
um
well I'm just adding on to what I've
said in Sue said um when Devon County
Council go on about Provisions are there
in the community for our areas
um
it's not suitable for people who attend
the link centers because of as I said
before severity levels and complex
um stage a little bit a lot of these
Provisions that they seem to think
there's plenty of are mainly for mild
mental health people who are having a
bit of strain need some support to help
with it perhaps get some resources from
what the Burton gallery and are fine
just popping in and you know being in
the public space and not worrying about
people looking at them and possibly
judging them so it's not suitable for
anyone who's got anything more than mild
um so when Mr McGinnis and his team have
gone on saying oh there's plenty of
provision there's plenty of groups
there's plenty of things in the
community by default it actually
excludes us because we can't just go in
the community in general Community
groups because of like social anxiety
Etc
um and they don't seem to acknowledge
the fact that
this is such a barrier when they say
there's provisions and they just assume
everybody can attend and they're not
thinking about everybody's needs there's
so many people have been excluded and
getting support
and it's it just seems to be very
short-sighted on their part and again
link centers is all in one it's for all
ages well from 18 up
um it's got all support for all severity
all complexities
um
and like
I'm just trying to put it into words
um
and it just seems to be so
again short-sighted and quite ignorant
of Devon County or particularly the
people that are pushing this forward
it's very yeah dismissive
that they are trying to close them and I
mean looking at
um information it would actually cost
more to provide in the community than
what it was with the links it will cost
more money per head per person
um to do that and it just seems to be
well if you're trying to like find
savings that's not the way to go you
need professional stuff as well don't
you like you mentioned before
and you can't expect it seems like
everything nowadays is relying on
volunteers to pick up the pieces where
people can't volunteer like they used to
be able to because cost of living crisis
the retirement retirement age is going
up how are we going to find the
volunteers and with those professional
skills as well and another point with
volunteers I mean
volunteers I mean that's hard work
anyway and like hats off to anyone who
does volunteer but there's also
especially when it comes to a difficult
job like providing support for people
with mental health illnesses there is a
high turnover
in people like doing it doing it for a
bit and quitting because they can't do
it anymore yeah you need the consistent
service paid stuff who will be um
consistency is very important to
people's
um being being for people's stability
and Recovery
um especially and like when there's
people who are lifelong
um you know lifelong illnesses
um that's when there's always people
talking and changing trying to restart a
relationship with a support worker is so
difficult it can take months before you
could even feel comfortable with opening
up to them if people are only there for
a couple of months and think then this
is not for me then even if they if they
start having a good rapport it can be
quite devastating to have to have that
change yet again
um I am open for a few questions as a
service suit if anyone's got any
thank you
thank you um Carl have we thought about
Sir Jeffrey Cox government at the
petition can we do a petition online 100
000 you know um signatures we'll we'll
get a vote
um we'll get we'll get it heard and how
far have we gone with that um chair I
haven't seen it social media and so
forth
I'm not sure but I was going to propose
that
um we asked Jeffrey Cox to come and
visit with councilor McGinnis because
I'm sure people saw that he went for the
one in ilford key yeah and the MP there
was support really supporting we have
had Jeffy Cox visit
um when was that that was the 23rd of
June I think he said to me yeah and he
was willing to come again in a few
months yes obviously
um but it would be great if we could get
that support and get him to come with
McGinnis as well
um that might be helpful because then
it's a they can both be there to see
what's going on
um also there is a petition at the
moment for to try and reinstate
referrals and the uh staff-led groups
there is a
petition online and on paper
um you've got the
yeah
the original petition the deer Type 4
700 signature and
we presented that to
open County and you didn't have the
response today no I never got a response
from Devon County about that
um
just wondering if there's a legal case
as well because obviously this is where
we we actually got our sister involved
um and when we challenge a certain what
a common I mean
I can actually tell you more detail
about
um what process and what angle we used
to challenge Devon County on that
there might be a way using legal aid to
to
might be something to
considered if it goes to court
I think one of the things I'd like to
pick up with you sorry if I can just pop
in I mean I've been a registered nurse
for nearly 50 years in both adult care
and psychiatry
and
so I've had a lot of experience of
dealing with all sorts of situations and
I think that the point that you made
about volunteers and Anna's made about
volunteers and and the staff burning out
is quite relevant but also and it cost a
lot of money particularly to individuals
if that's a requirement for them and it
does put an awful lot of pressure on
people but they also need supervision
and that's why it's important to
recognize Devon partnership trusts role
in this because they provide as the
mental health provider for Devon the
supervision for their staff
and that's why I'm really surprised that
they haven't been more engaged in this
process and I've pulled off all the
literature on dpt's website and on one
Devon's website and the consultation
process isn't recognized at all on
either of them
so it's this is about buildings because
that's the only thing that Devon
partnership that Devon County Council
can actually consult on because the
buildings belong to them the service
doesn't belong to them it belongs to the
service users and to Devon partnership
trust and I think that's another
challenge that needs to be made
thank you
um what about
the discussions
yeah would you like to come and speak in
um
can I just um mention that Celine Saxby
has already brought up about the links
in Parliament and the
um answer from the health secretary was
that they have sent us enough money
and they have sent us enough money
because
for the first consultation on the 8th of
December 21
before this February one about closures
um there was 3.5 million being signed
off while we were under the lockdown
um with the Devon Mental Health Alliance
and that was in the November before we
had the cabinet meeting in the December
21.
so there is plenty of money it only
costs 480 000 for all four centers for a
year and Adam Carrick gets half of that
on his own
250 000 so two directors across Devon
get as much as it cost to run four whole
towns here sorry I could go off on a
on a tangent so I'll let you have your
um Jane Cannon I'm a service user and
I'm in danger of going off on a soapbox
so I better go and sit down
I think you should
another thing we're mentioning was about
rural deprivation and well not just
rural in the towns as well around here
and obviously central government have
picked us for the leveling up
partnership because they've recognized
we're an area of deprivation so surely
that should highlight the need to have
these sorts of services in this area
because they've recognize that we're an
area of deprivation so it makes no sense
to cut them
just
yeah so would you like to come in yeah
I'm Sergeant Glenn Clark I'm a noble
team leader so I look after Biddeford as
a community
um so away from welcome up to sort of
Wesley kind of way
um
uh apologies first off from inspector
Seer who is due to be here but for what
you said
that's I really appreciate that
um I joined the police to help people
most police officers
want to help people and something which
I think is really relevant to to this
I don't want to call and say I'm putting
fuel on the Flames but it's quite
relevant that people should know this is
that
um we the police have got a new policy
coming out soon but which is right care
right person
um
historically police when people ring up
police they want help
and we want to provide that help
and be it criminal matters or for people
who are in distress they're unwell and
they want to reach out because they're
frustrated but they might not get the
support from other agencies to help them
so when they ring police we want to try
to help them and I'm not a trained
physician I'm not a trained mental
health nurse or
psychoanalyst or psychotherapist but we
would try to help
um we're now the police are going to be
using my person over the next one year
two years to actually disengage from
what we've done historically
um we're actually putting onto the other
agencies to do more support
and to signpost people at the first Port
of Call which is a telephone call to
police to say you need to
go and speak to whoever it is in Devon
or wherever
please get involved with people as I say
with telephone calls
um we've got a duty of care we've got
preserve life however with the right
care right person coming in we'll be
doing less engagement with people
so
the call for help needs to go to someone
to help those people because we're
coming out and disengaging I've got a
quote here from the chief Constable Andy
Marsh who's College of policing CEO
talking about the right care right
person
um
policy that's going to come out he said
the public want police catching
criminals and protecting them from harm
attending mental health calls is not
always appropriate and these changes
will strike a better balance so that
public receives the service they want
so police will be doing policing
possibly more so than helping people
with Mental Health crisis
so
whatever happens now if we're not
answering those calls to help people for
mental health
we still would we will go to those
courts I've read that somewhere here but
who's to say those smaller issues that
we're turning away might not turn into
bigger issues later on so that's why
it's quite important that this is raised
so that we can help people because
that's what we want to do
thank you that's really useful I didn't
know about that new policy
we've got any questions from you I just
we do have a just one more thing just we
utilize section 136 powers on where
people are on Bridges
um or have overdosed and they need
immediate care control
that does take away a lot of police
officers so when we use the section one
three that person to a place of safety
the nearest place of safety is Exeter
and we can only go to Exeter if there is
a bed there a provision for that person
to be seen by the the correct people if
they haven't got a bed available the
next Port of Call is Plymouth
if they haven't got
bed
I think it's Torquay
um so sometimes there's no beds for
Devon and Cornwall we can't share
other Provisions section 136 wise we
can't share other
places of safety outside of Devon and
Cornwall borders
so we end up then with a person in
Mental Health crisis waiting for a place
to be available
for them to perceive the care and help
that they need so there were police
officers four we can hold them up to a
fair while but and that's not the best
for them and unfortunately taking
someone down to extra Plymouth
who are socially anxious anyway
and totally out of their comfort zone
that just makes it even more so of a
concern for them and so that's that's it
from police perspective
what about in terms of increases in
mental health call outs to the police
there's
um
as I said earlier I apologies I think
I'm sort of forewarned as well with
stats
I know that we have quite a lot of calls
made to us from people who need help
um and it's because that sometimes
there is confusion about who to turn to
in the first place because there's so
many things out there but in actual fact
that's all over the place on the
internet they don't actually know
who is the right person to talk to to be
able to trust in the first place so
there is an increase in mental health
course if there wasn't that's why the
right care right right person
um policy wouldn't have come into effect
so um I think someone said there was a
quote I think it's going to save about
in a year a million police hours
policing hours in a year the right care
right person because of the amount of
time for the call and then
begin to go if especially if we haven't
got these types of centers available
yep
do you want you better take the thing
again
um I just wanted to mention that kehum
Kiam in Plymouth they had a disaster of
a shooting and a lot of member of the
public that needed victim support and
the 1.2 million that was sent to
Plymouth went on call centers more about
80 more people in call centers and it
went on CCTV for the streets it hadn't
actually reach the people to help people
except under the 136 because if it's
gone into CCTV call centers and and this
kind of thing then it's not actually
there in the services we haven't had a
penny in our services over the last
couple of years
um and the 480 000 we did have was for
the managers for all the staff and they
did all the work themselves you could
have one member of Staff looking after
seven clients and helping them to do
cooking to motivate them to look after
themselves
you could have one member of staff to
seven clients so where is the value for
money in all of this because are we just
spending all of our time putting money
into things that are not even reaching
the services like send 160 million today
I heard from the cabinet in debt
oversend but we're in special measures
the money isn't even reaching the people
it's meant to reach so it's all a
nonsense the whole thing is such a
nonsense especially the money
and we had 15 million across the county
for mental health and the government
already told Celine Saxby 3.5 million we
know went to governmental health
Alliance and they have the same address
in Plymouth as mind we haven't even seen
them and the whole thing is about
communicating with us and there hasn't
been any
and we can't even get Mr McGinnis to
come to Biddeford and you couldn't even
get him to come to this meeting and it
says a lot about communication and I
remember at one of the meetings in Devon
County Council where he said if we
listen to the people we'll never get
anything done
obviously they need to listen to the
people a good half an hour with our lot
in the client in the link center would
have been enough for them to realize how
stupid they've been and how
irresponsible they've been over the last
three years and how many lives they've
actually affected and they've affected
all the services all the health services
and pulled them out from under
everything
and we had 308 per 100
000 people
self-harming outside north Devon
District Hospital during the pandemic
when these centers were closed and the
and the national average was 187 per
hundred thousand and that's in their own
statistics
so you tell me whether closing the
centers had any impact or not because
the national average would be as high as
the link center average otherwise
308 000 people 308 people per hundred
thousand and the national average was
187 so they couldn't say that it was to
do with this site or the other we're
making all these excuses because it's
the it's the pandemic or because it's
the living cost of living crisis they
make all those excuses but actually
they're the people who are really making
a waste of time with all the money
they've used the money to throw it out
to oh word there sorry thank you thank
you for your input I go off on one I'm
sorry that's part of my problem and at
the end of the day you mentioned uh as
it's about saving people's lives isn't
it it's a life-saving service that we're
talking about
so should we make a few
should we make a few recommendations or
are there any other questions uh
councilor craigie well I was I was just
gonna sort of draw out the figures
because we've actually got it in our own
benchmarking
um done in 20 2022
that in storage there was 213
39.2 100 000 of uh
Hospital emissions due to intentional
self-harm which is
a whole 60 people per 100 000 more than
the national average for that year
the figures actually show that North
Devon is close to 3 300.
which is our neighboring Authority and
also covered by the link centers
and the the suicide rate again has has
been mentioned
and is again in our own benchmarking
figures
um
our figure is 12.4 as opposed to the
English average of 10.4
so that means a whole two people every
year dying in torrage
above the average
um
and again as uh my father canceled
Thomas pointed out that mid devans even
higher than that and that's in again our
figures in our benchmarking the county
knows this
and yet they've shown a level of disdain
not only to the users
but to the community and to this
committee for not even being willing to
come given the amount of effort that you
took as chair to try and arrange an
appropriate time to be completely
dismissive and not showing any
willingness to engage with us whatsoever
in our statutory role of of a scrutiny
body to be a critical friend to the
county
the the level of disdain that they have
shown us is shows there under the Care
Act and Care under the mental health Act
they are not fit
to manage that Duty and I think that we
need to in the strongest possible terms
explain to them that they do need to
engage with the community they do need
to be realistic on the figures and they
do need to meet their statutory duties
whether it's whatever the financial
burden is because that's a statutory
Duty about people's lives and every
suicide is not one person it's a family
and that's that's a huge number of
people that are then traumatized and
then I've got other mental health
concerns
it is
like an infection that seeps through our
entire Society if we do not
deal with minor Mental Health
it escalates and I was only at the
Children's Center in Biddeford last week
when they said that the biggest referral
they get to support Young
parents new parents is mental health
problems
by an OA the largest reason why people
are referred because they can't cope
with the amount of stresses
and I think we there is no way that the
county is taking the level of of problem
seriously in any way whatsoever
surely if the counter counts were
confident in what they're saying what
they're proposing then they'd be here
today and they'd be explaining to us
what is available and why they're
confident with what they're proposing
but they're not here they're hiding
they're hiding aren't they because they
know that it's wrong and they know that
they shouldn't be doing it but they're
there in Exeter and they they've decided
not to come up to torridge in North
Devon
um yeah Sonia
um
I don't know if um
that's supposedly a full page
spreadsheet of provisions
for
our area we've constantly asked for
those
they're still not here
so I haven't seen any
evidence of
so it's all just lip service really with
no real plans behind what would actually
happen if the link centers weren't here
um
I mean I think we'd all have a lot more
confidence in what the county was saying
is if they actually provided the
information whether when asked
the fact that they haven't provided the
lists of what these alternatives are
supposed to be kind of makes you wonder
if they exist at all or if they are as
Sue has said entirely on the internet
and therefore not really based here in
North Devlin at all because they could
be anywhere there could be a call center
in
in in China for all you know but to say
that that is
the where
people should turn to doesn't really
reflect the amount of people in in our
area that don't use the internet the
amount of uh mental health problems
which actually inhibit people using
telephones and calling out for things
actually a lot of the the crisis that
the extreme end that the police will see
is because people haven't been able to
ask for help before that point and it
has just poured over in into that
extreme and I think it's the importance
of the link centers has been that it can
catch what is relatively maybe a mild
situation to start with but because if
there's no intervention or no we've
really got to hammer this home because
otherwise we're just going to be there's
going to be an avalanche of problems
yeah and they'll ask us why we didn't do
anything to stop it
uh councilor Thomas
um just a quick question
um we've talked about the county having
a statute of Duty
who actually assesses and judge judges
how they perform and whether they
actually meet the statutory Duty how's
that evaluated
would you like to answer that question
I'll have a go Individual Services are
assessed by the Care Quality Commission
but that's health-based services
so CQC will look at the things that
Devon partnership are doing they're
currently recognized as good
but the link centers aren't mentioned in
the Devon part of the individual Service
as as in the north Devon link centers
but they do assess different partnership
on the basis of the community services
they provide
and as far as who assesses Devon County
Council basically it's self-regulatory
they are looking at the
indices the kpis if you like that they
set
and the top one
is about financial the financial
situation not about the success in
meeting care needs
surely there must be some somewhere
within the government set up there
should be some way of evaluating whether
a local Authority meets its statutory
duties in which case can we as a body
appeal to whoever should be regulating
that
go take it to a higher level yeah who
would be the minister
Secretary of State for that it might be
a minister or Secretary of State but can
we find out who it should be in relation
to the provision of mental health okay
and let's take it to them
okay should we put some proposals
together then oh would you like to speak
they say that they are doing that they
are making sorry there is the 2014 Care
Act which the council say that they on
the consultation that people that come
into that will get the help they need
but there is also the 1910 uh 2010
equality act which
makes sure that people have the
opportunity of of doing with reasonable
adjustments of being able to do the same
things that people that don't have some
sort of disability or mental problem can
do and that is the to demand equality of
equal opportunity
um but you fill it for me and then if
then you might have to argue with a
solicitor so there is a 2010 Care Act
but it could be quite difficult to get
to to show that you are not being
tracked equally like the the rest of the
um population thank you because you
might need a legal legal help do you
mind saying here you are as well oh
sorry um I'm Linda Ellis and I'm a
health people
uh we're all counts as we probably
received the LG GA Magazine first if
those of you who have read it probably
saw there was an article in it that the
majority of those uh authorities that
have responsible statutory
responsibilities under the Care Act 2014
are failing to meet them
um so obviously the LDA is well aware
that uh it's not just a Devon problem
that it's actually wider than that but a
degree of honesty from Devon County
about its ability might be uh helpful in
actually getting to resolve these
problems because no problem that is
thank you
just wondering how we go about it so I
propose then that we ask our MP
um oh sorry councilor Hardy
yeah I mean um basically I've had two
breakdowns in my uh life uh I had my
first mental breakdown and uh
um
2006 I think it was and then the the big
one when when I um lost my business and
everything
um back
um in uh 2017. and um both times I went
to the doctor and the doctor
um recommended me to talk to somebody
and I had that and that was on the phone
um when I had my big one
um I had someone in Biddeford High
Street I went to see never ever offered
link or anything like that it was uh it
was just very much just me and the
therapist or me and a doctor and um and
you know like I say it's difficult um
you know like it's
is something that I don't know who is
responsible you know and uh
it it'd be nicer we had a lot more help
I must admit
can you thank you for sharing
um we've been discovered as well a lot
of them incentives
haven't had statutory care assessments
me not to have one as soon as possible
and most users have no idea how to go
about
um asking for one
um
we we were just we discovered well
someone else discovered and let me know
um but there is a way to ask for an
assessment by basically doing an
assessment online
um to ask on
um it's a bit of a Minefield and people
need support for that but we also have
to ask getting people to like
do that like with support
um but again it's
not knowing it's people not knowing how
to go about stuff and like GPS seem to
be confused under over what they need to
do to because they just think you know
refer to the Community Mental Health
Team but uh and not via this way but
there seems to be a lack of clear
process
how to go about getting particular types
of support I mean the statutory side is
like going up to a community mental
health Team getting therapy with a
psychologist or going to a psychiatrist
for a diagnosis things like that but
there's also the non-statutary part
which is what the links cover as well as
anyone under the statutory care because
as again like I said before it's an
all-in-one because a lot of people won't
qualify for statutory care but they
still need the support to stop
themselves from needing that
can also say that the online
because I I went to see the online one
myself
and that uh
like a pre-surveyed before you actually
get to
what which is just I love to do and I'll
come to that it doesn't sound very
accessible to a lot of people who are
needing to use bad enough just doing one
type of question because I've been
doing a survey beforehand
Council Hawkins just had a question
about the right care right person
um I'm assuming the police are changing
their policy in order to bring that in
and
I think like you suggested it would mean
you'd have more time to concentrate on
other things because you can
pass over
somebody with particular problems
to the right person to give the right
care
who is that right person going to be to
give that care have they
have you got a group
in mind that
oh you think
are they
it's interesting reading and objectively
looking at the right care about person I
can see what they're trying to do
um
it's going to be easier in some areas
than it is possibly for Devon and
Cornwall because you've got four
different
um
Partnerships for hospital
um organizations so
it's going to be I don't know how
they're going to roll it out in in Devon
and Cornwall because
um they've given a time scale of 18
months that hasn't started yet but I
know in other areas Metro Metropolitan
Police it started homicide
um that's where it's it's
originated from and and seemed to have
done well there so I can't answer your
question but it has been rolled out in
other areas so maybe if you do some
research
you can see how they've been successful
in what they're saying is the right care
right person
and presumably you'll have a harder job
in Biddeford and North Devon because
there won't be a right person
you know what the one one thing we'll
say is
being a being an agency we do work with
other partners you know NHS mental
health teams that they have they they
are doing
a job which
without them we wouldn't have helped as
many people so I've got to say first off
that there are these agencies these
organizations that have helped people
um but what we're saying here is if
we're losing something
and how who's going to take that place
I can't answer that because I don't know
the answer to the right okay right
person because I haven't been part of
the policy for Devon and government
please
just wondering the part of
um
what we're considering with the link
center proposals will the police be part
of that consultation because you
couldn't including that about these
changes that are going to be made and
the extra importance of places such as
the link centers to provide that
provision because you won't be able to
as a police service because you're more
based on taxing crime rather than mental
health so we we have a lead that that is
rolling out the right care right person
in the force and if you want to make it
as an action that I can
send an email to to the I think it's the
Chief Inspector who's part of that
process to bear that in mind
um maybe to be quite quite aware of
scrutiny panels and what their their
views are around the local Authority I'm
sure that we've got the right care
available for the people that need it
yeah and I can send that into mind
because obviously the police are going
to be referring people but they might
not have the right place to refer them
to
oh you know then that's this is where
um and all jokes aside where I am just
Sergeant at least I can say I will send
an email on behalf of the police and
Care reply back to and bring it back to
this this committee that's not a problem
do we need to vote is that if you want
we need to vote for them
well can we just put that as an action
yeah that'd be brilliant thank you no
problem
any other questions before we wrap up
yep go then
the workings of uh County Council that's
it
no do you know Stacy do you know legal
stance yes they can you have to raise it
as a complaint with the authority first
of all
so you can't go straight to the
Ombudsman you have to raise it with the
authority first of all let them respond
to that complaint and then you go to the
ombudsman
who would make the complaint anybody
anyone can make a complaint to the local
authorities yeah
if I can just ask it seems that the the
making the complaint to the local
government Ombudsman is an individual
not a collective group that can make a
complaint is that the case
anyone can so I think it can be an
individual or group
could another local Council on is that
not
or could the committee make a complaint
yeah okay so
yeah well but I don't think your best
routine is by a councilor Hudson on the
sorry Council Hudson but she is our
representative on the Devon County and
at the moment that's how we've been
advised so we can put forward through
councilor Hudson
our concerns and what we've discussed
today and how important the link center
is and we'll do that I think
as a result of today's meeting but if it
continues and it looks like the closures
will happen and I suppose that's when we
could take it further and make the break
things out forever and ever if we go
down the sort of formal committee
process can we as a committee
investigate What mechanisms there are to
raise our concerns to a higher level
whether it's the local the
Ombudsman or to a relevant minister or
some other body
can I propose that we actually
investigate
how we can take our concerns to a higher
level and follow that route as well as
the route through the county has that
got a second
yeah all in favor of investigating a
route
unanimous thank you
have you got that Karen
have we got any more
yeah you know miss us
can I propose that we just have a
standing invitation to Devon County and
then they can turn up to any meeting
that they want to so that we can ask
these questions
already
auditions and they their feedback was
that we need to go through councilor
Hudson so
I don't know if it'd be helpful if
cancer Hudson sorry Council Hudson again
to put you on the spot but the committee
that councilor Hodson is attending is
specifically for this this work to be
done so councilor hodson's been put on
that committee as toridge's voice and
and our representative so I think it may
be best to funnel it through and then
she can speak at that committee I mean
the committee is open to everybody and
to watch it's going to be online or
permission if counselor Hodson wants to
explain
what's been happening
I have the microphone
[Music]
I've been listening with interest and
that's why I'm here today because uh the
first meeting I attended at the County
Council not just representing torridge
but I've been chosen to represent all
the districts in Devon
which is you know quite a weighty
responsibility
um
it was terrific that and organizations
who actually tackled head-on where is
your evidence for making these decisions
actually caused the whole meeting to
take a different
path and that is why they've
um
withdrawn the current proposal
extended the provision until
sorry
I'm gonna get told off again I'll hold
it so I can see the green light shining
so the issue for me is they were told
that evidence was totally flawed
and they didn't have anything to back up
what they were proposing
so they have gone away to work and find
out exactly what the situation is I
think one of the key things for me
is if you turn the tap off
the bath doesn't fill up
in the same way if you turn the
referrals off
to going to these link centers your
figures are going to look very small and
very minimal and not very effective
so I think that's one thing I'd like to
see us or your good selves because I'm
not on the committee looking at as to
trying to get that referral
pathway
reopened
and I am concerned about the fact that
if you you don't have you don't fit in
quite the right box for mental health
assessment
that you have seen as too problematic to
deal with
because who actually provides those
services and I think as a community we
should be asking those questions
so I feel very strongly about this
because
there are people I've met who have had
Mental Health crisis we have one of our
counselors but so many people
come up nearly to crisis if they can
come in and get some support it actually
it doesn't go away but it helps and it
doesn't become a crisis situation
requiring hospitalization or massive
drug
treatment
so I think it is a key thing for all our
communities because what is the stat one
in four of us will have a mental health
problem
I sometimes wonder when I listen to some
of the nonsense that's being discussed
whether the statistic is higher but I
will endeavor and I can assure you if
you feed me the information anything you
think is relevant my details are on the
way we're a great chat and it was really
and it's a great place to be
I wasn't aware of that I'd never been
there before but it's a place I would
definitely recommend to others if they
were allowed to go but this is the
problem you have to be referred
so I think that's key for your committee
thank you thank you
also at the meetings anyone can register
to speak as members of the public can't
they and attend them it there's scrutiny
meetings at County Hall they're open to
the public and anyone's meeting
but there were quite a lot of speakers
uh I think you probably have to register
to speak in advance yeah uh there may be
a limit on how many people they allowed
to speak
and as yet there is no date for this
coming back to committee
because the next scrutiny meeting is
dealing with other issues
um
they're dealing with Dentistry which is
also interesting for us
um digital strategies
and I'm trying to write my breath I'm
rack
in hospitals
there's a report coming about that a
briefing about that
and when I asked about this sufficient
time
yeah
that hadn't been sufficient time to
actually deal with the issues so but
that will be coming back to a future
meeting okay thank you thank you for
that update yeah
yeah and I just want to say that it is
really good that we've got councilor
Hudson on that committee but that she is
only one individual on a on a committee
um
and putting a lot of weight on one
individual to make the entire case for
our area so I think we do need to also
use other avenues I know Stacy likes to
keep everything simple and down the line
but we do have to use every Avenue that
we've got to keep the pressure on and
because it's it's it's a political issue
but it is an issue that affects everyone
across the the community and
this committee again it has that role to
be the critical friend of other public
bodies and what we've got to do is is
say
when we feel
that they need to think again and pause
and consider
because it's our residence
that are impacted by these decisions we
might not have Direct Control
but at least we can keep on raising it
and flagging it up to them so I think
that we we need to to write to them and
complain about the level of disdain that
they've shown this committee that
they're not even willing to it to
provide a statement or information
will come and explain anything that
they're going to do because or what
while they do have a duty to
to be scrutinized by the the County's
scrutiny committee
what purpose does this body serve if
it's not to provide
an extra opportunity and level of
accountability that is the one thing
that democracy is good at is everyone is
looking at everyone else to make sure
everything is done appropriately
it's not just to clarify it's not
necessarily me trying to keep things
straight down the line I think one I
know from bitter personal experience
councilor Hodson never lets anything go
I think that the difficulty that you've
got potentially is that they're not
going to respond necessarily to us
um if we go through all different
Avenues
um I promise you if those points are put
forward to council Hudson she will raise
her and that's part of the reason why
Catherine Hudson was selected not only
because she's got a particular interest
in this sorts of
um area but because you know she's
prolific when it comes to putting those
points across but she's also lead member
for housing and it probably would have
been quite um interesting to have one of
our housing team here today
um so overall I'm I'm ahead of housing
and this issue affects us and like it
will affect the police as well
um quite quite substantially so I put
that across to council Hudson a lot as
well because as you'll probably know
when it comes to
our homeless duties
housing has probably last on the list in
terms of assistance that people need so
we're very keen to be feeding this stuff
up through as well as long as aside with
the 18 plus we're losing a lot of the
funding from that so everything is up
for consultation
and what they're effectively saying to
us at the moment is we're still under
that consultation that's why we're not
responding to you and that's why we're
not going to come to your committee so
I'm not saying don't do it I'm just
saying I would be doubtful if we'll get
a response at this time while it's still
being scrutinized by counties committee
now I think if it comes to the point
that after those points have been put
through that they still make the
decision I think then you turn to have
your your second attack on it if you
want to I just yeah I just don't think
they're going to respond separately
because what they're saying to us is
we've got this committee they're
reviewing it you've got your
representative and as councilor Hudson
said not just for Torrid actually for
the whole of Devon
so I mean you know I'm not trying to
prevent it I'm just saying you I think
that would be the better better course
of action for this time being but accept
your point
yeah I mean I have
foreign
just come back what we mustn't forget is
on that committee alongside myself
we've got cancer Helia who's one of our
councilors
and North Devon have got representation
and for the
I can't remember which one it was I'm
sorry I'm not
um
was it
councilor crab
right
um so we have got people within our area
who are going to be affected and
representing people so I think it might
be useful
uh to
keep them informed about the actions of
this Committee in looking at this issue
and how supportive we are of the link
center and how what part are they
prepared to play
have you got a proposal then councilor
craigie
that we could vote on
our alternative suggestion is if they
want to close the link center
and I think we need to continue to keep
the pressure up
on them and and actually be treated with
some level of respect
on this because there is a huge
disrespect the people that didn't come
here to talk to us
I think we need to keep putting the
pressure on so I second that please
um all in favor
is that unanimous is that you as a
counselor unanimous there we go
so we're going to investigate where we
can take it higher and we're going to
send a letter to your county
um
inviting them again and the disrespect
for them not attending
and
any other proposals from anybody else
yes so I was going to propose that we
asked Jeffrey Cox and councilor James
McInnis to visit the link center
together
um
in Biddeford
and for our MP to publicly support the
continuation of the service
and I think we should include in the
invitation the councilors the county
councilors in the area so you mentioned
councilor Helia and councilor Crabb and
any others that we
yeah I also think that when we write to
them that we should demand that they
immediately reinstate the referral
routes until they've decided what
they're actually doing
because they're all people that need the
support right now who could just
have access even if their intention is
to close it later those that
makes a difference that they'll have
some support for some period of time
so that
so I've got here as well I was going to
propose that this committee supports the
petition to reopen all the referral
routes to the link centers in biddiff
advancement ilfrikim and reinstate staff
LED therapy groups as they were
pre-covered so people can get the help
that they desperately need so I was
going to propose that we support that as
a committee and also that we um
recommend
oh it's on here
it's the Bold fit in there
and so as a committee we support it and
we recommend that full Council so
towards District full Council also
supports it
um
have you got a second there
all in favor
not taking it okay so
all in favor apart from one abstention
the petition one
should we do the proposal to invite
Jeffrey Cox and James McInnes and the
county councilors to support it can I
propose that separately and then we
might get a unanimous decision all in
favor
so it's unanimous too
oh cancer craigie
then we can say that the committee
unanimously
invites our MP and councilman chemists
and our County councilors to the link
center to get their public support
for the continuation of the service in
support of all of our local communities
councilor Burke
sure if it hasn't already been done can
I also suggest that the police
commission also expresses concerned
about what is going to happen when they
start
um
not responding if you like to the
questions of you know individuals who
need help because it's going to put an
enormous amount of more pressure on the
Health Service and so forth so perhaps
through our Sergeant Glenn there he
could comment on that thank you you can
write a letter to the um the independent
Office of the police and crime
commissioner okay
and ask about right care right person
and we'll raise that with councilor
Hackett who attends the meetings as well
thank you for that
do we need to vote on that
okay I think it would be unanimous
anyway also proposed that we ask about
holsworthy situation because obviously
it is a closed one and
although we want the referral routes
open we want holesworthy to be habits
provision
so he that's the shepherdino the
Youth Center has got a service but
there's no trained professionals there
at all
it's run by volunteers
um
we have been told that the link center
is never going to be opened again
it will be nice if that wasn't true
but it'd be nice to know what's going on
so the feeling in holdsworthy is that
there is a need for trained
professionals to be able to provide very
much so provision very much
um who is that something we would
and also councilor Hudson you'll take
that forward
I got told off about last night I forgot
to switch my button on one juncture
um
yes it's just about how we do this when
you say you're going to invite Sir
Jeffrey and our County councilors
where are you inviting them to
I think Center
how have we got the consent of the link
center to have a visit
with those people well we discussed that
when we had our me when we went up yeah
um to the link center and it was
something that the um users previously
he would come back in a few months it's
sort of a reminder that he needs to come
back and to bring councilor McInnis with
him
right so we've just got to affirm that
the link center are okay with this for
the visit
because that it's not us up to us to
invite
to an establishment which isn't in our
so we could recommend remit recommend
that they attend
well you know we quarterly request the
the company of their map and width that
we go to yeah and that's something that
this committee could ask of us
frustrating as the the head of the the
link center service he'll be able to
make a determination on on when
um and we'll ensure that it's arranged
okay so with holesworthy do we need to
do some
um okay
uh do we need to find out more about
what what's needed and what's happening
or evidence
I think we need we need from County what
their plan is to do because my
understanding was that the the amount of
funding that the youth service the youth
club got was only for a one-year period
and whether they're going to continue
that funding even for the voluntary
service and obviously that funding was
inadequate to provide for professionals
um and so it was only a short-term thing
and we need to know what the long-term
plan is
building is obviously still there it's
it's been inhabited at the moment by one
individual with extra needs but it'd be
nice to know from Devon what their plans
are for that building I know our County
councilor James morrish is quite Keen to
find out too
um but it's it's worth knowing what what
the plan is I think we should put that
as an extra action then find out exactly
what's happening with the holsworthy
area
please since the closure of the link
center
okay okay so at the moment I think
I would recommend that you have a
conversation with the leader of the
council because he's aware of the
situation as is our counselor from
holsworthy as well but there are groups
providing differently we need to know
what direction everybody's going in
before we leap in with our size tens and
maybe create a problem where there isn't
a problem but I do recognize the fact
that it's about the professionalism of
the support services you give and are
those professional requirements being
met elsewhere to support the people who
go
to the youth club provision
so I don't know the answer to that and
those are the sorts of questions you
need to be asking okay
sorry at the last committee it was
requested that we make contact with
um
people from Holland and wall
um and from petroch the college around
apprentices so I've spoken to Chris
Fuller who's the economic development
officer and he's passed on some contact
details which I've made contact with so
I think we've got
um petrocker or the name sorry cmtg
there you go yeah
um and we get to hear from Holland and
more
and Christopher is going to come to that
meeting and I've asked if he's available
yeah so yeah we've started sending out
invitations because north northern Devon
Futures that would be linked to that
with Chris Chris is part of that this is
part of it yeah
um and then December I didn't know
whether we might have a joint meeting
with North Devon
on either Dentistry or agriculture
whichever fits in with their committees
if everyone's happy with that
should we leave it leave it like that
and then it keeps it more flexible for
going forward
um
I think that's it
everyone happy
oh that it was brought up yesterday
internal scrutiny about lendology
um
being discussed Brooke they they were
happy to attend that they
um linked to
affordable housing and
autopsy
in the empty homes yeah that's it
um
so maybe we could put them on at some
point
they'd be happy to have hadn't I'm
delighted to actually I've already
spoken to them about um coming and doing
a presentation oh right
um so yeah they're really really Keen to
do that so should we put them in if
nothing comes forward with North Devon
Council on agricultural Dentistry then
we'll put invite lendology
does that sound okay cancer craigie
um okay
um I was also just going to pick up on
the the Pickwell Foundation because they
are impact moving
ship scheme
um at the end of June
in this coming year they're going to
have another family in Biddeford
um so it'd be better to get them in
before that so on perhaps April or March
well we're very happy to come and speak
as well they are working alongside us
with the Ukrainian families
um so I've already spoken to them and
said actually there will be one of their
reports coming out in the members
bulletin this week
um but whenever you yeah they're very
happy and would actually yeah love to
come over to you all about the work that
they're doing okay so you thought that
maybe April might be a good time should
we just put them in for April and so we
don't forget it and then
foreign